(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
And tonight, guest shark
LORI Greiner joins the tank.
I'm gonna write you a check
right now.
Hopeful entrepreneurs
come to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
I see you making
stupid decisions right now.
Okay.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
when was the last time
you held a check for $500,000?
How could you say no?
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
This is an outrage,
a form of financial pornography.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
Don't walk out of here
kicking yourself.
It's sink...
whoo! (laughs)
You have to say yes
right now.
Or swim.
Every tear I cried
and every prayer I prayed...
has brought me here.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Lori Greiner is
the queen of qvc.
She holds 108 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing $500 million
in Worldwide retail Sales.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
First into the shark tank
is ivori tennelle,
who believes she has
a new and improved version
of a ubiquitous product.
♪♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is ivori tennelle,
from Irvine, california,
and my product is the swilt.
I'm here asking for $30,000
in exchange for 35% equity
in my company.
Now you're probably asking
yourself, "What is a swilt?"
Well, let me tell you.
The swilt is for soccer moms
sitting on cold metal bleachers.
It's for frequent fliers
in airports
who are riding in planes
and want to be comfortable.
The swilt is also for...
sports enthusiasts...
(chuckles)
Who are cheering
in the stands.
(Robert chuckles)
No longer will you have to lug
around sweatshirts and blankets.
I've married the two
and now they're all-in-one.
In on-the-go mode, it wears
just like a normal sweatshirt.
In head-to-toe mode,
two snaps in the front...
unhooks and converts it
into head-to-toe mode.
In head-to-toe mode,
it has a foot pocket,
and one of the wonderful things
about the foot pocket
is that it is lined
in Water-resistant nylon,
meaning if you're sitting
somewhere and it's, like, damp
or disgusting things
on the ground,
all you have to do
is wipe it off,
roll it back up,
snap it into place, and it's
right back to on-the-go mode.
I just have one question
for your guys.
Who's ready to
get comfy with me?
(Robert, Lori,
and daymond laugh)
Ivori, how many have you sold?
So far,
we've only sold 100...
but that was just because we've
been at local Marketplaces.
That's why I'm here today.
People don't know about it,
but if they knew about it,
they would love it.
(Kevin) That's always
the problem, isn't it?
Don't you hate it
when that happens?
I know, I know, and--
so what would you do
with the money, ivori?
We need
web site optimization,
so what we'd do is
We'd change the WEB site around
so that
it's search engine-friendly,
and because I know, when
people know about his product,
we are going to sell out
of what we have--
so what we need
is more inventory.
(laughs)
You said
you're in some stores.
What kind of stores and...
Oh, no. I said we're in--
I have done, um, marketplaces,
meaning I have gone
to a marketplace and--
flea markets,
that type of thing?
Exactly, and people have said,
"you guys are too big for this."
Like, we've actually been there
and people have come up to me
and said,
"you guys are too big
to be here."
Have you gone to a store,
knocked on the door,
and said,
"Here's what I got. Buy some."?
this is the beautiful thing
about it.
No one has really seen it,
so you guys are--
you guys can take this
wherever you want to take it.
There's n--We're not
tied down to one chain
or something like that. We--
that is wonderful,
so I'm gonna offer you $35,000
of Daymond's money for 20%.
(Robert)
She only needs $30,000 Kevin.
Ivori, don't you think
it looks like a thirt--
something a 13th-century Monk
would wear? I mean, look at it.
I keep on waiting
for somebody to pop up
going, "Omm. What is..."
are you saying
it's ugly, mark?
I'm not saying it doesn't work,
ivori, but when I look at it,
I think 13Th-century Monk,
Grim reaper.
I think,
"if I put one of those on,
I fall flat on my face
'cause I trip on it."
I just can't get my arms around
it as being a success, ivori,
so with that, I'm out.
Okay, let me
tell you that--
now you came here
for daymond.
He's the fubu guy. He's done
this fleece wear thing before.
Go get him.
This is for any of you guys.
(daymond) That's right.
Let's st--
Let's start with him.
Some people are--
you know that one blanket
with sleeves that made millions?
That thing is
silly looking to me.
(Kevin) the snuggie.
(Lori) Here's the thing.
I'm very good friends with
the guys who did the snuggie.
They're
my infomercial partners.
And they have sold
billions of dollars in snuggies.
I mean,
they were everywhere.
Mm-hmm.
Totally saturated
the market.
Do you see the snuggie
anywhere now?
Exactly.
No, and the reason
you don't--
but, Lori,
you could get in now.
The reason you don't
is because
the market is just
completely saturated with it...
the snuggie is dead?
You're kidding.
And the prob--
the snuggie is dead...
but What about the swilt?
And the problem is,
the swilt is really just another
iteration of the snuggie.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Ohh. Ivy, that's bad.
I would have to say
absolutely not.
This is actually mobile.
You can't take the snuggie
outside of the house
or Someone would say you were--
looked crazy, right?
You can actually
wear this out.
I don't know if it's attractive.
I wouldn't wear it.
I'm a diva and I wear it.
Ivori, there's only one path
for you to get that money here,
and it's daymond.
I'm out. Go get him.
Ivori, uh, when you roll it up
into on-the-go mode...
mm-Hmm.
As you've got it now, it looks
like you're wearing a tent.
I don't find it attractive.
I mean,
it just doesn't flatter you
and you're a good-looking woman,
so I'd lose that roll
because We're all trying
to lose our rolls,
and you've just made a roll.
Okay.
So, uh,
I hate it for that,
but we all know
that the real opportunity
is between you and daymond,
and I'm gonna hand it over
to him by saying I'm out.
Good luck with Daymond.
E's the last shark in,
and I know he loves it.
(laughs)
Daymond, do the right thing.
I think that
you have a lot of drive
and there's other things
that you'll do.
You'll learn from this
and you'll create
something else,
but I-I can't add any value
to you, so I'm out.
Okay.
(Robert) Ohh.
(Kevin) Daymond.
Good luck, ivori.
Okay, thank you.
(Lori) Good luck.
Good-Bye. Thank you.
The Snuggie's dead?
The Snuggie's dead.
Can we please hold hands
and have a moment of silence
for the snuggie?
♪♪♪
My name is Shelly ehler,
I live in
Ladera ranch, california,
and my business is show No.
My husband Brian
is my high school sweetheart.
We've been together
for 22 years,
and now I'm a mother
of two adorable boys.
My boys Love
going to the pool...
Kiss. Jump in.
(yells)
but it's always a hassle
to change them.
The wet clothes
are stuck to them,
and to try and get them off
while keeping them covered
is really a challenge.
And I came up
with a perfect solution.
Right now I'm sewing every
single thing from my house,
and it's a lot of work.
I need help.
The recession
hit Brian and I really hard.
We owned a printing business
that just was not
recession-proof.
Brian and I had to sell our home
and we had to move.
It's been
the most difficult thing
I've ever been through
in my life.
I need this deal
with the Sharks.
Mmm.
Group hug.
My family's future's
riding on it.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Shelly ehler.
This is my son Max
and this is my son Clark
and we're here to present to you
our show no towel.
We're asking for $50,000
for a 25% stake in our business.
I got this idea when I was
at the pool with my sons.
They wanted to change
into their dry clothes.
My older son asked me if
I would make him a towel tent,
which basically means
to take your towel...
and wrap it around them
so they can change their clothes
without anyone seeing.
Well, while we're waiting
for him to change his clothes,
my little guy started
getting a little impatient.
(mark and Robert chuckle)
and it was one of those
kind of mom moments
that you wish
you had four arms
so you could hold Everybody's
towel and make everybody happy.
And it got me thinking,
why not take a towel...
put a slit in it.
They can wear it
like a poncho...
(chuckles)
and they can change
without anyone seeing them.
And then the name
just shot out at me.
It's a changing towel,
it's a poncho, it's a show No.
Heh.
We made you some custom
"Shark tank" Show nos...
Awesome.
That the boys
are going to pass out.
Thank you.
Mr. Cuban's getting
the mavericks blue,
daymond, you have purple 'cause
I notice you wear purple a lot,
and, uncle Kevin,
you get green.
Thank you.
It's the color
of your favorite thing.
Green's the color of money.
That's right.
Wave Bye to the sharks.
See you guys.
(Robert) Bye.
This idea is exploding,
and I need your help.
I'm not just here
asking for money.
Truly, I'm looking for a mentor.
You know how to do it.
You've taken simple ideas
and made multimillion
and -billion dollar companies.
I've not one single doubt
that working together,
we could do the same.
Are you making these
at home by yourself?
Primarily, I have been
making these at home.
I've seen ponchos
like this before.
I have seen, um, towels
with a round circle in them.
The thing that I really like
about the show no
is that it lays completely flat
and it closes up.
So if you were to lay it on...
the SAND or something like that,
you would have
a complete towel.
(Lori) Did you patent this?
Yes. You know, I did not have
a lot of money to start this up.
And I just kept thinking,
"how am I gonna do this?"
and then the most incredible
thing happened.
My husband and I
were selling our house,
and a new neighbor
was moving in two houses down,
and we were having
a going-away party.
So as they're over,
we're talking and she was
complimenting my drapes--
I made custom drapes
in our house--
and I said to her,
"So what do you do?"
and she said,
"Oh, I'm a patent attorney."
A patent attorney.
And I went, "Oh, my gosh.
"This is meant to be.
This is another sign,
this is right,"
and we traded patent work
for drapes.
You traded patent work
for drapes. Okay.
Oh, you traded?
That's pretty cool.
Wow.
I have to tell you,
when I saw this idea,
I said, "This is huge.
I've got to take this big."
and then I thought,
"Okay, water parks.
That's the perfect place
to showcase this towel."
I came up with the idea
of putting the custom name
of the park on the ribbon.
Good idea.
Good, Yeah.
It's--makes
the perfect souvenir
and great advertising
for the park.
I've gotten accounts so far
with legoland california,
six flags magic mountain.
It was a hit.
How much do you
make the product for?
It costs me $6.50
to make this towel.
(mark) and you sell it
to the water park for how much,
and at retail for how much?
I sell it to the water parks
for $9
and I sell retail for $19.99.
And the water parks--
how big an order did they place?
Oh, now we just started,
so it's not huge.
My biggest order right now is
from legoland california,
and they've placed an order
for 240 towels.
So far I've sold $15,000.
(chuckles)
So, Shelly, there's a bit
of a problem here.
$15,000...
is pretty well a nothing Burger,
to be honest with you.
Your enthusiasm is--is good,
you know, I have to admit.
But what's sobering are
the sales.
You have
a very, very seasonal business.
You have to stock heavy,
spend your capital,
hope like hell
they sell through.
The focused seasonality of that,
I do not find attractive
as an investment.
I'm out.
Okay. Okay.
I want to also point out,
when I first started, I thought
of it as seasonal as Well,
until I realized that it is
the perfect bath towel for kids.
Kids love using This towel
every single day at bath time.
There are over 1,000 water parks
in the United States.
I figure, if I can get
at least 50 of them,
and I think--
and I know I can,
if I can get at least 50 of them
to sell 20 towels a day--
that's doable, 20 a day.
They're open 3 months a year,
90 days. That's 80,000 towels.
That's almost $1 million
in 3 months.
You could sell
$1 million worth of towels
just to 50 water parks?
I think I can.
Maybe.
I love your passion.
I mean, uh,
you're--you're so committed,
but I've gotta be honest
with you.
I'm not as excited about
the product as I am about you.
I don't see it selling.
I'm out.
(mouths word)
Let me ask you
the most difficult question.
Yes.
You have
two beautiful children...
yes.
And it's a birthday.
Right.
The C.E.O.
Of a major corporation
wants you to come out
and make a presentation
to all their buyers,
and the only day
that they can see you...
right.
Is on that birthday.
What happens?
I will go and be part
of that meeting,
and I'll tell you why.
I shower my kids
with unconditional love.
They are my life.
They are my everything.
They know how much
I love them.
It doesn't matter
where I am.
They love me so much
and want me to succeed so much,
They would push me
on the plane.
(laughs)
My husband is
so supportive of me,
I would not be here
right now
if it weren't
for all that support.
I am not here standing alone,
I'll tell you that.
You know, my husband and I got
hit hard with the recession.
I've never been through
anything like that in my life.
We've had
four REALLY rough years,
and I have to say...
(exhales deeply)
Every tear I cried
and every prayer I prayed
has brought me here, right here
to this moment in front of you,
and I would not change
a single thing.
I know it's meant to be.
I like it, I mean, but the sales
are really challenging,
and--and you're saying that
the company is worth $200,000.
Okay, I-I understand
that my numbers did not
reflect that...
Yeah.
But I have to tell you,
I have a call in
to a connection
with--with Disney right now,
and it's very recent.
I haven't heard anything back,
but I'm gonna keep working it
until I get it.
Well, Shelly...
I'll--I'll offer you
$50,000 for 50%.
I'm gonna tell you
what I think.
I think I see
a ton of me in you.
I love your drive.
I love your passion.
I-I relate to you.
I've been on qvc for 14 years,
and I know what it takes, too.
I started making
everything by hand.
I like you so much that actually
what I'm going to do is,
I'm gonna write you a check
right now.
Oh, my God.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
and Shelly has two offers
on the table,
one with an interesting twist.
I'm gonna write you a check
right now...
Oh, my God.
For the $50,000...
okay.
For 25% stake...
Oh, my gosh.
And all I'm going to ask
of you is...
Yes.
Is that you will put
all that drive and enthusiasm
into helping me...
Yeah.
And you get that
into every single Theme park
that there is
across the Country.
Hey. What am I, chopped liver?
Hold on. What's going on?
Then maybe we need to do
$50,000 for 20%.
The check's written, Shelly.
Shelly let me just add
something here.
I see a lot of potential,
and to me,
that potential is worth more
than $50,000 for 25%.
So I'll offer you $75,000...
(Kevin) Ooh.
For 25%.
Shelly, what's
the advantage that I have
over these other sharks here?
Qvc.
Qvc, and I'm a woman.
We speak the same language...
what does either one have
to do with it?
And you know that
you and I are going to have
a great time working
together,
and I think with my ingenuity,
added with your ingenuity,
we will turn this
into a dynasty...
well, Shelly, here's what I--
here's what I have in common...
of more...
with you.
Show nos.
I know
the C.E.O. Of six flags.
I already work with the C.E.O.
Of bed bath & BEYOND
AND buybuy BABY.
THEY SELL MORE TOWELS
THAN YOU WILL EVER SELL.
I'VE BEEN A VENDOR
OF J.C. PENNEY'S FOR 20 YEARS.
RIGHT.
THAT MEANS WE'VE MADE
A LOT OF MONEY TOGETHER...
RIGHT.
AND I PROBABLY AM SELLING
ALREADY 2 MILLION TOWELS A YEAR,
AND I'M GONNA MATCH
HIS $75,000,
BUT FOR ONLY 20%.
OH, MY GOSH.
I'LL MATCH THE $75,000,
STAY AT THE 25%.
IT'S RIGHT HERE.
YOU CAN GRAB IT.
SHELLY, I'M SURE
YOU ALL WOULD BOND,
AND YOU GUYS COULD GO OUT
FOR COFFEE,
YOU COULD HAVE
SOME ICE CREAM,
AND YOU WOULD BE BUDDIES
FOREVER, RIGHT?
RIGHT.
WE ALL HAVE CONNECTIONS.
I MEAN, J.C. PENNEY'S IS
IN DALLAS.
YOU KNOW, THE C.E.O. COMES
TO MAVS GAMES.
I WAS INVOLVED
IN THE TAKEOVER OF SIX FLAGS.
CONNECTIONS ARE
THE EASY PART.
MY HUSBAND'S HERE.
IF IT'S OKAY, I REALLY NEED
TO--TO DISCUSS THIS WITH HIM.
SURE.
(Robert) ABSOLUTELY.
STEP INTO THE HALL.
WE'LL HAVE SOMEBODY
BRING YOUR HUSBAND IN.
OKAY.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
(whispers) OH, MY GOD.
(exhales deeply)
(Kevin) I JUST WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING HERE. I'M STUNNED.
YOU'RE LETTING A WOMAN
WITH AN IMPASSIONATE PLEA
WITH A SLIT IN A TOWEL
SUCK YOU IN...
I'M MAKING TOWELS ALREADY.
LETTING HER CRY A STORY FOR YOU
AND INCREASING THE PRICE
BEYOND ITS wildest metrics
and value...
This price means nothing if I
just put it into my fabric Run.
Is a form--
is a form
of financial pornography.
We've got kids watching
this show that are learning...
(laughs)
Exactly the wrong thing.
This is an outrage.
They all have
so much to offer.
You know, mark is so sweet
and he has--
he really believes in it,
and daymond has
all these connections, though,
in terms
of his manufacturing.
I'm disgusted.
She has what it takes
to drive this business,
and, I feel, joined with her,
we can take this everywhere.
I already have five ideas
of how to make this even better
than what it is.
I just don't want to make
a mistake,
'cause I know daymond has
those incredible connections
in terms of Manufacturing.
He already makes
millions of towels a year.
Yeah.
He has connections all over
the place in terms of that.
You know what's best, baby.
Just follow your heart.
You know. Babe, you know.
I--
I know.
(whispers) I love you.
I think that
we can make this huge.
Are you not getting caught up
in her emotion? Be honest.
I love her emotion, but no.
I'm a businessperson.
(exhales deeply)
because I'm indifferent,
I'm gonna tell you this.
In life, there's only
a few moments that matter,
and clearly this is one
for you.
You have a towel
with a slit in it...
(mark chuckles)
That somebody's willing
to offer you $75,000 for.
Right.
Don't screw it up.
(chuckles) Good advice.
I am so humbled
in this moment right now,
and I thank you all so much
for hearing me,
for getting it,
for believing in me...
but in terms of going
with my heart...
I have to say,
I'm gonna go with Lori.
I'm so glad you made
that decision.
Thank you so much.
Ohh.
I'm not liking
this girl power thing.
(high-pitched voice)
Come here.
I can't wait
to work with you!
(high-pitched voice) Oh!
She was the right partner,
mark.
No. That was not
the right partner.
Thank you.
No.
You're welcome.
Ohh.
Take this check
to the Bank.
Okay. (chuckles) I promise you,
I will not let you down.
That, by the way, is a first
on "Shark tank."
She believes in you
so much, Shelly,
she's not willing to do
any due diligence.
(daymond) Yeah, that is a first.
You could be--
you could be an ax murderer,
and you'd still get that money.
She's not. I can tell.
(voice breaks) I did it.
(Shelly)
I am just thrilled beyond words.
This is incredible.
Dreams really do come True.
(voice breaks)
You can dream something,
you can believe in yourself,
and it really can happen.
♪♪♪
In season 1,
D.J. And Sean came to the tank
with their
internet company notehall,
which allows students to buy
and sell Class notes online.
I don't know who the shark
is here. I think it's you.
They left the tank
with a $90,000 deal
With Barbara Corcoran.
You're dead to me.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
After being on "Shark tank,"
the BUSINESS world took notice.
We got calls
from all over the country.
There you go, sir.
(D.J.) in fact, one of
those calls was from chegg,
the number one textbook rental
company in the country,
but they weren't looking
to invest.
They were actually looking
to buy the company, and, uh,
they gave us an offer that
we just couldn't refuse.
(Sean) We can't disclose
the exact amount,
but I can say
that we're millionaires.
Congratulations. Well-Done.
Yeah. Good stuff.
Excellent.
It's nice to have
a couple millionaires
working for me.
(both laugh)
(Sean) and not only did chegg
buy the company,
they gave us jobs
at the company, too.
Hey.
Hey. What's up?
Did you guys see
this latest design?
How's it going?
Man, that looks great.
When you start a company,
you're so passionate about it,
getting acquired, getting bought
is what your dream is.
That's what you're going for,
and to actually, you know,
live that dream,
to be in those shoes,
I couldn't be happier.
We couldn't be happier.
Definitely.
It's unbelievable.
Looks great online.
Looks great.
Kevin O'Leary called us
the sharks,
and maybe he was right.
♪♪♪
Hi. My name is Kelly Chaney.
I'm from
pittsburgh, pennsylvania,
and I'm the owner
and founder of puppy cake.
I'm seeking a $50,000 investment
for 25% equity in my business.
I used to work
for a sales and marketing firm,
and one of my clients made
cake mix for people.
As I was looking at my Client's
old cake mix advertisements,
I thought to myself,
wouldn't that be great
if they made that for dogs?
So I researched
canine nutrition,
and I eventually developed
puppy Cake.
Puppy cake is similar
to cake mix for people.
You add egg, oil, and water,
mix it, and then bake it.
Each box comes
with yogurt frosting,
and all you do to that is
add water, whip it up,
and top the COOLED cake
or cupcakes.
One box of puppy cake bakes
six cupcakes
or one 4-inch round cake.
This is Minnie.
She's a 7-year-old vizsla,
and she loves puppy Cake.
(baby talk) Minnie,
would you like a puppy cake?
(normal voice) Here you go.
That is a wheat-free
peanut butter Puppy cake
That's topped
with Our yogurt frosting.
Puppy cake is literally the best
thing your Dog will ever eat.
Why can't you just make
a regular cake?
A regular cake is not gonna
be good for a dog.
Uh, dogs have
unique digestive systems,
and we've chosen ingredients
that will be safe for dogs.
Do you have
any sales of puppy cake?
Yes, I've been doing--
Minnie.
Easy, Minnie.
Minnie, come on, honey.
You'll get some later.
I've been doing this
for about four years,
and I've had over $80,000
in sales over the 4 years.
What about last year,
Kelly?
Last year, $23,000 in Sales.
Is this through the internet,
or do you sell to stores?
I do sell to stores.
I'm at about 150 retailers,
and I am international.
I believe that this is
a very viable product,
and one reason why
I believe that
is I have done almost
no advertising in 2011,
and I've gotten some
really fantastic publicity.
I've gotten featured
in "Modern dog" Magazine,
"the bark" Magazine,
"Pet Product news
international."
Like, it's--
I've never heard
of those magazines.
Those are dog Magazines.
Dogs read them.
P-people who--
(laughs)
Kelly, do people buy it
to really make the cake
or as a novelty?
They buy it to make
the cake.
Isn't there a stretch here?
The inconvenience of having
to bake a cake for your dog...
my mother-in-Law makes
cookies for her dog.
Yeah, but...
(Robert) she does?
She does.
What percentage
of the population...
she loves her dog
like a child.
Has time to say,
"honey, let's not make
dinner for the kids.
Let's make a cake
for the dog."
(chuckles)
Actually, nestle purina did
a groundbreaking study,
and one of the facts that
they found was that
43% of dog owners celebrate
their dog's birthday.
Okay, but that's once a year.
That's True,
but do they make them a cake?
Once a year.
That could be one choice.
Um, that's one way
to celebrate a birthday.
Well, you see,
the problem with that...
the problem is...
(speaks indistinctly)
Every year you get to sell
one package to one person.
That sucks.
Well, imagine this, okay?
There are 70 million households
in the United States alone
that own at least one dog,
so if we're getting
a potential--
and every year
they buy one package?
Well, if we only get
1 1/2% of all households
who have dog owners,
that's a million boxes.
Kelly, you've been
at this for four years.
Yeah.
Why is it that you think
you've only grown it
to be able to do
$23,000 in business
over the past year?
The thing that I lack the most
is capital and connections.
I've never attended
a trade show
because I don't have
the capital for it.
I can't get
in front of distributors
unless I go to trade shows,
and that's why I'm here.
I'm seeking an investment
in order to be able
to take my company
to the next level
and attend trade--
but you could have called
distributors.
I have called distributors,
but I can't--
and what did they tell you?
I don't get
a return phone call.
Have you tried to go
to dog pet stores
and Places like that?
Have you tried to cold-call,
walk in and just say,
"would you be interested
in my puppy cakes?"
a couple times I have.
Um, sales is not really
my strong suit, and I--
I noticed.
(Robert) Ooh.
Kelly, I-I love my dog,
but I-I don't see the market.
It's a novelty. I'm out.
Kelly, you're saying
that a regular cake isn't good
for a dog, but how many dogs die
from a piece of human cake?
Not many.
Would you give your child
something that you knew
was not good for them
and that would upset
their stomach?
Yeah, but dogs aren't that dumb.
They know what they should eat
and shouldn't eat.
I don't think
there's anything
that would actually
support that.
A dog will eat, um,
they will eat something
that's bad for them
that tastes Good.
Well, I know for sure,
you can get a new dog
any time you want.
That's for sure.
(laughs)
Well, I can understand
how you may not
personally empathize
with this product.
No, I don't, actually.
You're correct,
but if I thought I could
make money, I'd be all over it.
I--
but this is a category
that I've developed
and is Growing.
Growing?
You got $22,000 in sales.
Have you done other--
I know you--you're
definitely stuck on the idea
that this is--
only happens once a year,
but I can assure you,
many of my customers buy
several times a year.
Oh, Kelly, no, no, no.
This is so wrong.
Thank goodness We've met.
I forbid you to go on.
I heartedly disagree.
Oh, my goodness.
It's insanity.
I believe that I can sell
millions of boxes
of these each year,
if I can get
a national distribution.
Minnie is speaking to me.
I can speak dog.
I'm listening, and she's saying,
"Please make her stop.
Please, uncle Kevin."
(laughs)
I howl at the moon for you.
Stop this madness. I'm out.
I-I'll tell you
what I think.
I-I love that you created
a birthday cake for dogs.
I think that's great.
I-I agree with Kevin that
the problem is--
is you're too limited
in your market.
People that have their dogs
love their dogs,
and they will,
I agree with you...
uh-Huh.
Spend a ton of money
on their dogs...
uh-huh.
But if you had a full range
of specialty gourmet foods
for dogs...
okay.
Which I think you should
maybe leave here
and think about...
okay.
But being just
one birthday cake for dogs,
I don't think that you're
there yet, so I'm out.
Okay.
Kelly, Kevin likes
to hear himself talk.
Unless you can sell it on qvc,
Lori just shuts everything down,
and it doesn't matter to her.
It's dead to her, so...
that's right. Encourage her.
Encourage her to go to hell.
That's so not True, mark.
(laughs)
The only place That's hell
is listening
to your nonsense.
What you have is, I think,
a good product...
thank you.
But you've had four years,
and you didn't feel like...
mm-Hmm.
Your back was
against the wall enough
to break through
your personal barriers.
Mm-hmm.
You know, you told us--
told us that
you weren't really
a salesperson.
To me, that tells me that
you aren't committed enough
to the product
to try anything.
I can't see writing a check
for somebody
who finds the excuse rather than
finds the opportunity,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
If I drop out,
you're not--
you didn't train Minnie to piss
on the carpet, did you?
(mark and Kelly laugh)
No, no. She's very Polite.
Yeah. I have two Puppies.
Uh... (chuckles)
Where I came from,
the dogs have it pretty rough.
They're usually out in the yard,
and, uh, their birthdays,
we just take the lid off
the garbage can for 'em.
(woofs)
So, uh...
(laughs)
Yeah.
And with That said...
ohh.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Well, I really appreciate
your time and your advice.
Go get 'em, Kelly.
You'll be all right.
Thank you.
Good luck, Kelly.
Later, Minnie.
(Robert) Thanks.
Today I think the SHARKS saw
my biggest weakness,
and that's where I allow excuses
to get in the way
of Making my product Successful.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank is
Eric corti,
with a unique way
to maximize the life
of a beloved beverage.
My name's Eric corti.
My company is
the wine balloon.
I'm seeking
a $40,000 investment
for a 30% share
of my business.
How many times have you said
to yourself,
"I'd love to have a glass
of wine tonight,
"but I'm not gonna open
that entire New Bottle just
"For one or two glasses,
because I know it's gonna go bad
by the time I'll have
a chance to get back to it."
Well, my wife and I love
red wine,
but it seems like
we've poured
more red wine down
our kitchen sink
as we've had to drink
in our house.
The reason
all that wine goes bad is
because those Primary wine
preservation devices out there
just aren't very effective.
You can pump the Heck
out of those rubber
stopper-type devices,
trying to create a vacuum,
but you can still see
half or three-quarters
of a bottle of air
still in contact
with your wine,
and the consumer doesn't even
know for sure if it's working.
I decided there must be
a better way,
so I created the wine balloon,
and here's how it works.
You lower the balloon in,
into the bottle,
till it's just
at the top surface of the wine.
You squeeze the grape cluster
to inflate the balloon.
As soon as it touches
the side of the bottle...
(chuckles)
It's completely sealed.
We say, give it
two or three extra squeezes.
Oh, that's cool.
Now that Seal is so tight,
you can turn this bottle
upside down.
That small bubble of air
in the bottom
is the only Air now
That's in contact with your wine
while it sits
on your counter like this,
in your refrigerator,
or in your wine cellar.
When you're ready
for another glass,
you just squeeze the valve here
on top of the grape cluster.
The balloon
completely deflates.
You just take it out,
rinse it off,
pour yourself another glass.
It's fantastic.
It's the wine balloon--
the wine preserver,
the only
wine preservation device
you can absolutely see
and know that it's working,
and I need your help to get it
to everyone who drinks wine.
Is this patented?
It's patent pending
right now. Yes, it is.
Okay. When--when did you file?
Eric, can I see it?
Absolutely. Pardon me?
When did you file?
How long ago?
Uh, I just filed recently.
About two months ago.
It was provisional,
and now it's a utility patent.
What is the rubber
that, uh, makes the bladder?
Uh, it is
a medical-grade latex Material.
Does it have any effect
on the taste of the wine?
It does not. It has, uh,
it gives off no taste
into the wine.
We've had it, uh, tested
in a laboratory
to, uh, confirm that--that
there's no, uh, transfer
of any flavors or--
how long do you think
it preserves?
Let's just take a Bordeaux...
mm-Hmm.
Which is very sensitive
to oxidization...
right.
And you--have you tested to see
how long it would stay fresh?
I mean, there's another system
That's very popular.
It's a shot of nitrogen gas...
mm-Hmm. Mm-hmm.
And then you Seal it.
Actually that balloon,
if you compress
an inch and a half or so
to the side of the bottle,
it will last
about three to four days,
but the beauty is,
you can squeeze it again,
if you're not gonna get
back to it.
For most people
with common sense,
they just want
to visually see
and know, uh,
that it's working.
The primary things
out there right now--
nobody can really tell.
You might say that gas is
a good preserver,
but I can't ever see it
or tell that it's happening.
Same with those pumps.
I can't really see
that there's a vacuum.
What is your background?
My background is
construction management.
Are you drinking
a lot of wine on the job?
(all laugh)
So how did you come up
with this?
Well, I have a lot of ideas.
I write 'em down
in a little spiral-Bound book
that I keep with me all
the time, that I travel with.
And how much have
you invested?
I've invested roughly $65,000
of my own money.
We just did a soft release,
uh, six months ago,
just put it up
on our web site,
with no real Advertising
or Marketing.
Sold over 700 units
to some Retailers. Um--
sold 700 units
at what price into retail?
Uh, at $22 retail price.
How--how, uh, much does it
cost you to make this?
It costs me $6.50 right now.
If you made 100,000 of 'em,
the price could be $2.50
to make them.
Very possibly.
You need a huge volume,
and there's hundreds
of thousands of the ones
that plunge air out
of the bottle sold...
right.
So here's a new idea.
We take it to that company
and say,
"Here's a better mousetrap
that replaces
your air plunging system,
which doesn't work,"
and I agree, it doesn't.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $40,000
under one set of circumstances.
I have no interest in going
into the MANUFACTURING business
or distribution business
with you in this.
I do believe
it's a better mousetrap
to the number one selling
wine preservation device.
I'll go with you
to that company, all right,
and negotiate with you
a royalty deal,
and I'll only get 30% of what
we make in perpetuity together.
Now I'll give you
a different offer...
okay.
Because I don't agree
with Kevin.
I don't believe that
you should be licensing this
and going to a company,
because you're gonna just make
a little teeny cut.
Right.
I believe in going direct--
times a million times.
Doesn't matter.
Sure it does.
The Lion's share is in going
direct to the consumer
because That's where you're
gonna make your highest margin.
Right.
This is your baby.
That's where you're gonna
make your money,
so my offer, I'm curious,
would you be interested
if I bought you out?
Potentially.
What if I gave you $500,000?
Period.
Straight up for the company.
I own the patent.
I own the company.
You go, Lori.
Potentially.
Eric, when was the last time
you held a check for $500,000?
I have never held a check
for $500,000.
What would that do
to your life?
Uh, it would be incredible.
It would be fantastic.
So here's a chance
with just one word...
right.
Yes. How could you say no?
It's gonna change your life.
I'll tell you
how you could say no.
You could think about
two years from now,
when everybody is using
this device
the same way they're using
the air plunger,
and you'll say to yourself--
and you still won't have
a half a million-dollar check
in your pocket.
And--and you have
no more upside to it--
wait, Eric. Lori, what if
we work together,
we increase the offer
a little bit? I'll go half.
So what you say is...
we'll go to $600,000.
$300,000, $300,000.
You accept her offer,
and you say,
"look, I'll--I'll take 3%."
You got it.
Okay. Eric, I'm gonna change
the offer here.
Eric, we call him
"The undertaker,"
because he is where
businesses go to die.
So not True, of course.
What Lori and I have
just decided is,
we'll go in this together,
and we're gonna give you
a $600,000 check.
Not $500,000.
A $600,000 check.
What does he get
in the future?
He gets $600,000 to inv--
what does he get
in the future?
He gets $600,000 to invest...
a brand-new home and a yacht.
In any other great idea
that he has.
He has an opportunity
to walk--
you don't get it.
You know what that means?
Look, you have
an opportunity...
you don't get it.
To walk in to your wife
and say, "honey, guess what?
I'm successful.
"I did everything
I dreamed of.
Look at this.
A $600,000 check."
but--but, Eric, in order
for you to be able to walk up
to your wife and hand her
that $600,000 check
and have your dreams
and her dreams come True,
you have to say yes
right now.
♪♪♪
Eric has two offers
on the table.
Kevin O'Leary has offered
$40,000 for a 30% stake,
while mark and Lori
have offered
$600,000
for 100% of his company,
but with one condition.
You have to say yes
right now.
And you know what, Eric?
Right now, Eric.
You're talking to a thief
who steals the future.
Right now, Eric.
And you're talking
to somebody...
this man is stealing
the future from you.
Who can get this on tv.
It doesn't even matter, Lori.
It's a highly
demonstrable Item.
Lori. Lori.
It doesn't matter
what she does on tv.
You won't participate
in any of that.
This is a thief.
How about we do that
with a 3% royalty?
It's not silly.
Whoa.
Yes, my man.
You're the man to know that
you have to keep your future.
Same thing.
Mark?
Always keep a taste...
mnh-Mnh.
Of your future.
Nope?
Mnh-Mnh.
That's how you get rich.
What he's talking about,
if this works, is chump Change.
He's stealing your future
from you. He's a thief.
What if we give him
2% royalty?
That's exactly what's happening.
No. No. No.
(mouths word)
We're taking all the risk.
Yes right now?
Say yes right now then...
I would,
if you accept the 3%.
Because, you know, I'll--
I'll tell you one thing.
I can't tell you how many people
have come up to me
with great ideas,
and they dickered
over, like, 1% or 2%...
amen.
Oh, I agree. Yeah.
And--and ruined the deal...
mm-hmm.
And today they're
kicking themselves,
because they're sitting
there with Nothing.
Pigs get fat.
Hogs get slaughtered.
Well, let's do that.
They're sitting there
with Nothing.
Let's not dicker over 1%,
and let's make it 2% then.
I'm out.
Oh. (chuckles)
Ohh.
Oh, look what you just did.
Ooh.
Oh, I'm sorry to hear that.
Uh, I'm--
y-you know...
take our offer.
Take the $600,000.
2% is not an option?
There is no $600,000, Lori.
Uh, he said he's out.
Mark is out.
Mark, would you come
back in if he s--
(mouths word)
You better take that deal
right now.
Don't forget my offer.
You don't want
to walk out of here...
you don't seem like
that kind of a guy.
No, I understand.
I-I've had, uh--
with Nothing.
Has anybody offered you
$600,000
in a single check,
one time, bang?
Have not. Have not.
And this is
your defining moment.
Then why would you--
you should take it.
So where are we right now,
Lori?
We're at $500,000, and if Robert
wants to go in with me,
we'll be at $600,000.
No royalty.
Okay.
You wanna go 50/50?
I'm gonna be out, Lori.
(Lori) Oh.
Now you're at 500k.
Okay.
Who else is left?
Lori, and, Lori,
you can--you can back down,
too, right?
If you want to go 400k--
are you back in, if I go--
200--I'll--
okay, now you're back in.
At 400k total,
at $200,000 and $200,000,
I will go back in.
$400,000--$200,000 and $200,000.
Hang on. So wait.
We're--
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What happened there?
Did you go down
to $400,000?
We did, because mark decided
that we should.
If he wanted back in.
He's aggravated.
Mark are you in at $400,000
with Lori now?
Yes.
Well, daymond, would you
and Lori split at $500,000?
I see you making
stupid decisions right now,
and I don't want to be part
of that. I'm out.
Two sharks are out.
Kevin's offer of $40,000
for a 30% stake remains,
while mark and Lori's offer
has shrunk by $200,000
in just minutes,
due to Eric's hesitation.
So where we are, Eric,
Lori and together will buy
your company--
no debt, unencumbered.
We own it. You have
a check for $400,000.
Right.
Eric, think about
What's happened here.
In the last few minutes,
$200,000 just disappeared,
just like that.
Right.
Are you gonna let
another $400,000 disappear?
Can we make it--
(Lori) take it. Say Yes.
Can we go to--back to $500,000,
and I'll say yes at $500,000?
Say yes at $400,000.
Don't walk out of here
kicking yourself.
I made you an offer.
What are you gonna do?
You'll take--
all right. Yes at $400,000.
(mark and Lori) Done.
Congratulations.
Hey, thanks a lot.
That's the best feeling
in the world.
Congratulations.
Thank you and thank you.
Thanks a lot.
You almost went to zero.
You're right.
I almost did go to zero.
Congrats, Eric.
Thank you.
I congratulate you
on stealing his future.
Exactly.
That's what you did.
We didn't steal
his future.
You absolutely did.
We made his future.
Kevin, you're just--
you're just upset that...
his future could have been zero.
You weren't in on the deal.
I--no, no.
I was never gonna deal.
If he has kids,
they're going to college now.
I would have never done
that deal.
That's right.
That is the beauty
of the tank.
I am a little disappointed
that we didn't get it
for $600,000.
We'll take it for $400,000,
but they are sharks,
and they got a little bit more
of what they wanted,
but I'll take that $400,000
and, uh, make something happen
with it.